under heavy security in the heartland of
where the indrangata hold power
the trial of more than 350 suspected
members and associates of the calabrian
mafia got underway
most of the accused appearing on video
link from their jail cells
no small achievement for prosecutor
nicola grateri
who's been working against the powerful
group for decades and as a result
has lived under police protection for
the past 30 years
decades ago people would tremble when
talking about the codes in austria or
when using the word indrangita
something they would do only in hidden
rooms whispering
today we're speaking out in the open
sunlight in the last two years we've
been seeing a spike in complaints
by people bullied by the indrangata
omerta is an age-old mafia code of
silence
applied through fear instilled by
violence in a population so as not to
tell
not to testify to the authorities but
around 900
witnesses are expected to be called in
this trial backed up by thousands of
hours of wiretaps
to help the case against the accused who
include politicians
police chiefs and lawyers most were
arrested in a raid in 2019
that spanned italy germany switzerland
and bulgaria
in the words of the chief prosecutor
this is a mafia that looks like us
and is everywhere one in three
restaurants in roman and milan is
operated by the drangita
by mafia organization called rangita
look around and
one in ten bank deposits is operated by
them
they are all over the administ
republican administration it spans
over five continents from germany to
colombia
from usa to australia with powerful ties
with the chinese mafias and many many
south american cartels the drangata is
said to be the most powerful of the
italian mafias
running most of europe's cocaine trade
with close ties to the latin american
drug cartels
it's believed to be involved in the
trafficking of weapons and people
as well as narcotics with an estimated
turnover of more than 60 billion dollars
a year
this trial focuses on one specific
family the mancusos
but there are others is made up of
different family dynasties
blood ties that experts say make it far
more difficult to infiltrate
or recruit informants the general
consensus here is that regardless of the
outcome of the trial it's not going to
affect the day-to-day operations
of the group but the fact that the trial
is taking place at all we're told sends
a strong message to what is one of the
most
powerful violent and richest criminal
organizations
in the world that prosecutors are on
their case and are determined to do
everything possible
to bring them to justice stephanie
decker al jazeera